[Musik]
mehr freiraum für geimpfte welche corona
beschränkungen für sie fallen sollen das
könnte sich in den nächsten tagen
entscheiden
verletzte und festnahmen in der heiligen
stadt seit tagen neue gewalt in
jerusalem zwischen palästinensern und
jüdischen israelis die polizei im
großeinsatz
silber und bronze in basel bei der turn-
em haben die deutschen andreas toba und
lukas fauser einen glänzenden tag an
reck und barren
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers die welt an diesem
sonntag herzlich willkommen bei uns und
guten abend norbert könig ist auch hier
für den sport ja champions league der
frauen geht auch genannt wir beginnen
mit einer ausgesprochen schwierigen und
zugleich drängenden diskussionen in
deutschland morgen treffen sich
bundeskanzlerin und länder chefinnen und
chefs um zu klären was geimpfte und
genesene künftig dürfen beziehungsweise
nicht mehr beachten müssen
es geht um gerechtigkeit und grundrechte
patricia wiedemeier zeigt die
standpunkte der zweifach geimpft ist für
den dürften bald wieder reisen in den
süden zum beispiel nach griechenland
einfacher sein
ab mitte mai verspricht die griechische
regierung doch in deutschland ist bisher
nicht einmal jeder zehnte vollständig
geimpft dennoch hält der ethikrat ist
für richtig rechtzeitig über ausnahmen
für geimpfte zu diskutieren
es müssten aber schieflagen verhindert
werden deswegen ist diese gleichstellung
von geimpften getesteten und eventuell
auch genesenen aus ethischer sicht ein
weg wie man möglichst breiten zugang
gewährleisten kann damit eben nicht
ungerecht wird eine beschlussvorlage für
den morgigen impfgipfel sieht vor dass
abhängig von der infektions lage und der
erkenntnis wie ansteckend geimpfte
getestete und genesenen auch sind
beschränkungen in leben und märkten bei
kultureinrichtungen beim sport und
dienstleistungen aufgehoben werden aber
auch bei einreisen und bei kontakten vor
allem in alten- und pflegeheim soll es
für geimpfte ausnahmen geben wie immer
den einen kann es gar nicht schnell
genug gehen die anderen warnen
ich bin sehr zurückhaltend denn wenn die
bundesregierung ausnahmen für geimpfte
machen will dann muss sie auch dafür
sorgen dass wir so viel impfstoff haben
dass alle nein impfangebot gemacht
werden kann wie beschränke mehr
freiheitsrechte und diese beschränkungen
sind nur dann gerechtfertigt wenn keine
andere möglichkeit besteht wenn aber
jemand geimpft ist dann muss er doch
auch klar muss er diese rechte wieder
einfordern können vom staat
auch die fdp fordert geimpften ihre
rechte so schnell wie möglich zurück zu
geben werden von bestimmten menschen
keine gefahr für die mitmenschen ausgeht
dann besteht keine rechtfertigung dafür
die grundrechte dieser menschen weiter
so stark einzuschränken und deswegen ist
es richtig dass diese menschen ihre
grundrechte wieder voll leben können
morgen soll es hier im kanzleramt auch
um diese fragen gehen doch solange die
dritte welle anhält wird es eine
aufhebung der grundrechts beschränkungen
wohl nicht geben
die strenge reihenfolge beim impfen
haben immer mehr bundesländer für den
impfstoff von astrazeneca mittlerweile
ganz aufgehoben und diesen damit für
alle altersgruppen freigegeben wenn auch
bei jüngeren nur nach beratung
was das bedeutet am beispiel hessen dazu
jetzt susanna von tina diese praxis in
wiesbaden gehört zu den ersten in hessen
deren ärzte gegen korona impfen durften
und die nachfrage ist seither riesig
gefragt ist vor allem der rna in stoff
[Musik]
die skepsis gegenüber ac e k
die ist bei den patienten sehr
ausgeprägt sind sehr viele die das nicht
möchten skeptisch zeigten sich hier vor
allem diejenigen die astra zenica
vorrangig bekommen sollten also die über
60 jährigen
während die jüngeren vor allem männer
oft keine bedenken haben nicht zur
klassischen risikogruppe gehöre
betroffen wollen jedoch überwiegend frau
von den nebenwirkungen von dem hirn will
thrombosen ich hatte richtig angst das
war mein kostenproblem hessen ist bei
der impfquote im bundesweiten vergleich
schlusslicht das land hebt jetzt in
arztpraxen die impf priorisierung bei
astrazeneca auf genauso wie vorher schon
mecklenburg vorpommern sachsen berlin
und bayern
nach ansicht von intensivmedizinern der
richtige weg viele plädieren für eine
generelle aufhebung der impf
priorisierung spätestens anfang juni die
hausärztinnen und hausärzte kern ihre
patienten am allerbesten und die wissen
wie man am besten zuerst geimpft und
darauf können wir vertrauen und das wird
dazu führen dass alle impfdosen
definitiv erhöht werden
etwa 23 der menschen in deutschland sind
mindestens einmal gegen korona geimpft
durch eine freigabe der priorisierung
dürfte sich die zahl bei deutlich
erhöhen
und da gucken wir jetzt auf die
aktuellen offiziellen corona zahlen das
robert koch institut meldet 18 1773
neuinfektionen innerhalb von 24 stunden
das sind 412 weniger als sonntag vor
einer woche 120 todesfälle kamen hinzu
die sieben tage incidents steigt leicht
auf 165,6 es ist ein verheerendes
unglück mitten in ohnehin schwierigster
lage bei einem brand in einem
krankenhaus im irak sind mindestens 82
menschen ums leben gekommen
es gibt mehr als 100 verletzte das feuer
brach auf der korona station dieser
klinik in bagdad aus möglicherweise sind
falsch gelagerte sauerstoffflaschen
explodiert viele menschen starben
offenbar weil sie von den
beatmungsschlauch das krankenhaus habe
kein brandschutzsystem teilten die
behörden mit
deutschland will indien im kampf gegen
die dramatische kronlage dort zur seite
stehen man bereite so schnell wie
möglich eine unterstützungsmission vor
sagt der regierungssprecher
ohne details zu nennen die eu will
indien mit sauerstoff und medikamenten
versorgen
indien meldet seit tagen immer neue
höchstwerte bei den crooner infektionen
vor allem wegen einer dort grassierenden
neuen virus variante das
gesundheitssystem ist völlig überlastet
es fehlen auch betten medizinische
ausrüstung und impfstoffe besorgnis in
israel nach nächtelanger gewalt in
jerusalem beruhigt sich die lage nicht
die auseinandersetzungen zwischen
palästinensern und jüdischen israelis
werden immer wieder auch durch videos in
sozialen netzwerken angeheizt
die eine neue art von übergriffen zeigen
michael bewerunge berichtet
tagsüber ist es ruhig an damaskus tor in
ost jerusalem
dort treffen sich nach den rituellen
ramadan gebeten vor der al aksa moschee
aber abends vor allem jugendliche
palästinenser die polizei verbietet das
seit tagen kommt es nun zu massiven
auseinandersetzungen in der stadt
es liegen steine und brandsätze die
polizei antwortete mit blendgranaten und
tränengas die gewalt eskaliert es gibt
viele festnahmen und verletzte zum glück
keine toten
die palästinenser leben die ganze zeit
unter dem druck der besatzung viele
haben keine arbeit sie können sich kein
heim bauen und wenn dann werden ihre
häuser oft zerstört
die gewalt ist die reaktion darauf es
ist nicht nur der ramadan angeheizt wird
der konflikt von solchen szenen in den
sozialen netzwerken eine araber schlägt
einen orthodoxen jungen andere bilder
zeigen wie offenbar junge orthodoxe
autos nach arabba durchsuchen steine
fliegen und die rechtsextreme jüdische
lehrer war bewegung zieht durch
jerusalem
es wird von rufen berichtet tod den
arabern der ministerpräsident rief zur
mäßigung auf wir ermöglichen die gebets
rechte in jerusalem für alle anwohner
wir verlangen aber von allen die gesetze
zu respektieren
ich rufe alle seiten auf die lage zu
beruhigen doch zuletzt flogen massiv
raketen aus gaza auf israel so viele wie
seit einem jahr nicht
israel antwortete mit luftangriffen aus
dem generalstab heißt es man bereitet
sich auf eine militärische eskalation
vor
und damit sind wir an diesem sonntag
beim sport und gespannt was norbert hat
ja erst mal fußball champions league und
zwar die der frauen
da ist der fc bayern münchen noch dabei
und hat gute chancen ins finale
einzuziehen
das halbfinal hinspiel gewinnen die
münchnerinnen gegen den fc chelsea mit 2
glänzender start des fc bayern zwölften
minute flanke glas der fehler von
chelseas torhüterin ann katrin berger
und der kopfball von sydney lohmann an
zu nur die führung
nur zehn minuten später freistoß stellt
sie und dann dieses unglückliche
gegentor hegering köpfte kurz an
ausgleich eins zu eins waren das bessere
team 100 zweiten halbzeit hanna glas
linksschuss 2 2 1 endstand und damit
eine gute ausgangsposition für das
rückspiel
die männer des fc bayern sind noch nicht
deutscher meister denn rb leipzig
gewinnt 2 0 gegen den vfb stuttgart und
verkürzt den rückstand auf sieben punkte
9 gibt es noch zu holen slowenische
erfolg beim rad klassiker lüttich
bastogne lüttich nach 259 kilometern
kommt es zum sprint auf der ziellinie
hat tour-de-france-sieger tadday boccia
einen hauchdünnen vorsprung vor
weltmeister juniors aus frankreich
bester deutscher maximilian schach man
auf rang neun und erfolgreicher
abschluss der ton em in basel mit bronze
am barren für lukas fauser und am reck
schafft andreas toba einen
hervorragenden zweiten platz
andreas toba gleich mit silber in seinem
ersten einzel finale bei einer
europameisterschaft 13 8 33 punkte nur
der neue titelträger belga was die aus
russland besser als torwart bewertet
eine stunde vorher gewann in basel luca
scassa bronze am barren punktgleich mit
dem schweizer baumann hinter dem
erfolgreichen türkischen
titelverteidiger arjan und dem russen
belgier ski ausgetobt
danke norbert dann schauen wir uns noch
kurz das wetter am morgen im norden
wolkig im nordosten sind regenschauer
möglich sonst viel sonne
die höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen 8
grad auf den inseln und 20 grad am
oberrhein
und ab dienstag wird es unbeständiger an
den temperaturen ändert sich aber wenig
so danke herzlich für ihr interesse das
war es von uns diese woche durch die
nächste begleitet sie petra gerster im
zdf-programm nachher das heute journal
mit marietta slomka sie hat fragen an
den bayerischen ministerpräsidenten